voilà monsieur bonsoir au soir du
troisième jour de la révolte du peuple
roumain contre l'ex dictateur ceausescu
la télévision annoncer la victoire mais
les combats se poursuivent encore entre
la population et l'armée ralliée au
gouvernement de salut national d'un côté
et les forces spéciales qui dépendaient
directement du dictateur
ces hommes n'ont plus rien à espérer
aucune retraite possible ils ont même
tout à craindre d'une population
terrorisée pendant vingt-quatre années
de dictature c'est pourquoi ils
continuent à se battre à bucarest et
dans plusieurs villes roumaines
retranchés dans des immeubles ou
embusqués sur des toits ils font régner
la peur et continue de tuer empêchant la
population de savourer une libération
qui de toute façon ne sera plus remis en
question jean-marc il use eric père
demandait rien à personne c'était un
gamin de 10 ans ils ont tué non
assassinés pâture
un témoignage parmi des dizaines
d'autres sur les actes de violence
gratuite des partisans de ceausescu
les partisans aux abois
mais qui aura entendu hier soir la
douleur d'un adolescent à sibiu bastion
de l'un des fils du dictateur déchu
sibiu tout à la joie de sa première
victoire sur les forces de la sécurité
presqu'au même moment à l'autre bout du
pays iasi 400 km au nord-est de bucarest
vivait ses derniers combats combes hors
de la victoire de m
des forts en vue aussi à l'aéroport de
bucarest enjeu stratégique majeur où les
pertes en hommes sont déjà énormes
premières images de reddition mais
l'aéroport est fermé les forces de la
securitate et n'ont peut-être pas dit
leur dernier mot
à bucarest même les symboles d'un
pouvoir tommy tombent l'un après l'eau
ici le siège du comité central du parti
communiste roumain seul détenteur du
pouvoir pendant 42 ans
au troisième jour des combats la
population toujours aux côtés de l'armée
pour répondre au feu sournois et
terriblement précis des miliciens sur
entraîné des charges
aujourd'hui à bucarest europe on meurt
et on crie l'armée avec nous
et la méfiance est partout ici
l'arrestation d'un civil
regardez il est du ministère de
l'intérieur
oui mais c'était seulement un type qui
travaillait à la comptine
méfiance guerre du renseignement
ici un commissariat improvisé pour le
tri de ce respect
puis inspecteur chef non il ment
à la télévision porte-parole clés du
nouveau pouvoir les émetteurs sont
encore intactes un commando a été
neutralisée de juste à ce matin
le studio de l'êta josu est transformé
en infirmerie
et on a même trouvé ici le coeur de se
détendre un peu en musique
ce